hi hi tell me where you grew up for
grave robbers so I am a
second-generation valley girl I grew up
in Simi Valley which is just north of LA
County yeah I did yes until there till I
was 13 when they separated so I grew up
in one cozy childhood home and ran
around with all the neighborhood kids it
was it was a good childhood I mean some
crazy stuff happened for sure but
overall I think I had a really happy
childhood and so I actually did public
school up until the ninth grade and then
in the tenth grade I started doing
what's called independent studies which
is like home schooling but essentially
you teach yourself the material so I did
that for the tenth and eleventh grade
and I graduated early and I did that
because of some medical issues but I was
going through at the time so yeah I was
able to graduate early even though I was
going through a lot of cool stuff
so after that I had a boyfriend all
through high school like a high school
sweetheart
and as soon as I turned 18 we moved into
like a one-bedroom guest house sort of
thing and that's when I started modeling
but I always had a day job too so work
all day at the mall and then do
freelance work on the side yeah
mainstream commercial and I did a bit of
fine art like nude modeling as well
I dabbled in that and I really really
loved that but I went and got a fashion
agent so they spent some time doing that
yeah
so about 20 years old I
decided I was done with fashion I didn't
want to pursue that and I just focused
on work working in restaurants and I
started going to school towards working
towards my aesthetician license and
every now and then I would do some
modeling jobs here are there some music
videos but it wasn't until I had my new
boyfriend at the time and he introduced
me to webcamming and doing live shows
online and I never heard that before and
all of a sudden I was getting paid to do
things I was already gonna do with my
boyfriend and it was a lot of fun but
then I got scouted and I was approached
via email by a talent agent and a few
weeks later I signed a contract and I
was doing porn and I loved it I went
from Cammy into porn mm-hmm because I
was scouted by a porn agency's yeah an
adult film talent agency my very first
scene was for tushy calm and it's a very
well-known site and it's very successful
and it's won many awards
and I had done lots of anal and my
personal life already and I knew I loved
it so I agreed to do it and I had a
great time like I was later told that
it's not a good idea to do anal so early
in your career but at the time I just
didn't care because I thought I know how
to do it I can do it so let's go and so
I was this new starlet who was just
doing crazy but stuff right out the door
but that very first scene to this day is
that one of the best scenes I've ever
done was with Manuel Ferrara and he is a
two-time male performer of the year with
the AVN Awards and and again I was 40
she calm so it was a very lavish set and
I was really pampered and I just loved
it I loved it so much so
well for me it's so many elements of my
life kind of accumulating into one
experience that I think I'm really good
at and not everyone's meant for it but I
might be sort of that rare breed yeah a
little athletic but yeah I did fashion I
did mainstream and I was more
comfortable being naked and so being in
front of cameras in the nude having like
sex which is something I was already
doing lots of off camera I don't know I
just the exhibitionist send me it really
bloomed I guess but I love I really
getting to know the people behind the
scenes actually there's this little bit
of a nerd in me that loves the techy
elements and the lights the camera the
action and and having to memorize lines
sometimes even if they're silly it's fun
because I get to do a little improv and
I feel a little bit more like a comedian
than the mattress but like convenience
and extras it's like but I also feel
like an athlete
I feel like an artist sometimes I get to
explore things that I could not have
ever safely explored in the real world
so I just feel really lucky
are part of your personality just like I
like getting my buttons pushed I do most
recently I travel to Prague to work with
legal porno legal porno calm and I did
three scenes which will come out over a
period of time and each one of those
scenes is a double anal so it's double
penetration to big dicks of my ass at
the same time and fisting definitely I
did a water sport scene as well so it
was a double anal water sports which if
you don't know what that is it's piss
play so being pissed on drinking piss
and at the end of it they peed in my
butt and I pushed it out so and I guess
that makes so many other so many people
uncomfortable but I've always been
weirdly obsessed with like what the body
can do and not grossed out by anything
in another lifetime I was probably a
nurse or surgeon
it's more like pushing my body and
seeing what I can do
and people think I'm well people who
don't know
so it's civilians will probably say that
oh she's dirty they're gross but
truthfully I shower maybe twice a day I
deep clean I scrub I take all my
supplements and take fairly good care of
my teeth and my hair and get tested
every two weeks so absolutely exactly so
I feel like this enables me to take care
of myself
out of level 2 which most people should
be taking care
Bua they are just sexually repressed or
is it just different strokes riveting
folks
I mean it's safe to say there's
widespread sexual oppression I think the
world would be a better place if people
were having not just more sex because
that's too simple but just more intimacy
with their own bodies and and the bodies
of others
I just think there'd be a less road rage
less violence in general so I don't know
I hope that maybe by shocking some
people I can start some conversations
even if it requires making people
uncomfortable at first and if you get
the chance to know me you realize like
I'm not this disgusting creature doing
some of the stuff that you do or you
know wish you did you have the Internet
by everyone and anyone even young kids
might be kind of undermining the moral
fabric of our society country
or children how do you feel about that
well I would strongly disagree
erotic art has been a part of every
culture throughout the history of
mankind so any fabric of society it's
already weaved into it this is nothing
from the outside this is not this is not
alien at all so I think that
Horace's
you ask the question again ii did just
like you many religious people are a
good example they tend to be like whoa
what you're doing is terrible it's
undermining tomorrow yeah the values of
our kids and right there all be
distorted you know personally I feel
that raising children deeply religious
is extremely harmful thoughts my opinion
I think that and this is not all parents
and all religions and all practices I
understand but your good conservative
folk are just teaching generations and
generations of the same fear of their
bodies that in her mom never taught her
how to take care of her body she says
she didn't know and her grandmother and
her grandmother and
I think that then you just open up and
accept that if they had there is a God
I'm pretty sure that God designed them
perfectly and you should not be ashamed
of anything that your body can or will
do or whatever you think I just embraced
being human and and I just disagree with
with not teaching children about bodies
and about sexuality because then they
grow up and they're adults and they're
running around confused and scared and
horny which is a really bad combination
and that's what you see when you're
standing in line at the grocery store
and you look around you and it's like
most people are probably in that state
and no wonder things are [__] sort of
boils down dude for me they do well uh
my mother is one of my best friends she
is very supportive she certainly doesn't
want to see anything but she just wants
to know that I'm safe and that I'm
healthy
and as long as I am paying my rent and
I've got food on my table she's happy
for me and everything else is extra so
everything else I've been able to do
with for my life she's thrilled I'm
incredibly lucky to have that she's a
saint of a mom honestly love you mom
my father he knows and in fact he was
the first person in the family to find
out which was weird um but he and I just
don't talk so it doesn't really matter
what he thinks but he certainly hasn't
disowned me in any way but we again we
already didn't talk so it's no big deal
I know my the rest of my family knows
but it's kind of an elephant in the room
but my family they all like grew up
conservative but now they're all kind of
liberal-leaning so they're just you know
they're not gonna get mad or kick me out
of the family holiday parties but again
they just don't want to talk about it so
I feel I feel lucky and not aspect
though like I have a family that knows
and loves me and still supports me so
there was nothing in your childhood that
kind of maybe directed you down this
kind of path or you think it's just
we're your
I mean it's definitely both I was very
sexual as a young teen and I just always
have been I've been very much in control
of my sex life and kind of like textbook
nympho but you know nothing happened to
me that is traumatizing oh absolutely
that's a great way to put that very well
said
yeah yeah you are sexual mm-hmm it's
hard to handle a person with agency
right so if you have a sense of agency
over yourself you know what you want and
you know when you don't want something
and people can't [__] with you and
people typically like to be able to
weasel their way in they want to feel
like there's a game they can play I'm
like no if you just come up show me a
clean test and ask me nicely then we can
talk it's also very interesting comment
and women will react differently to
someone like you oh absolutely
cold right yeah I'd use their head
already a man will be like tantalized
and why was that interested absolutely
but then the shame comes into play right
uh-huh
all of a sudden you're dirty even though
he's as attractive as anyone right he's
the most attracted he's the reason for
the product
it's just projecting yeah it's
projecting insecurities oh and lessly
fascinating I think I learn it all about
what I can do and then something new
happens and not until last years or so
I've started partying but I was really
well behaved I mean I smoke pot and I
drank booze with my punk rock friends
but never really any hard drugs nothing
crazy I just now as a young adult I've
tried some psychedelics and stuff but
yeah I was just kind of a low-key kid
well yes and no the crazy thing about my
teenager is if I want to die even though
that is that I have a pacemaker yeah so
I mean you can kind of see it here yeah
a nice scar so I got that installed it
was November 4th she's out 2008 so the
day Obama was it like did I have an
electrical blockage in my heart and
so this it's not they they did a genetic
testing and looked for it and they buy
their records they don't find it in my
heart code or whatever they did um but
there's no history of this in my family
they don't really know what caused it
but at 15 years old I had a pacemaker
installed so that's why I left public
high school in tenth grade so after that
happened and I recovered I just wanted
to live life to the fullest and I
haven't looked back ever since and here
we are 11 years later and I was like I
didn't think I'd even make it this far
but I am due for my first battery change
so that's something I'm looking forward
to in the near future and doing what I
do now is one of the only jobs that I
can imagine having without student debt
where I can afford health care so I did
go to school to get my aesthetician
license that's beauty school mm-hmm
that's like a very tiny debt I'm not
worried about it
but yeah I need health care and I've
been extremely anxious about that my
entire life and the system just kind of
keeps getting worse so it's something
I'm pretty passionate about and yeah I
think that's kind of where some of the
crazy starts if you want to call it that
yeah I am 26 closer to your mama your
dad as a child my mother definitely yeah
yes
he was pretty textbook alcoholic and
we'd be gone sometimes for days or a
week at a time
and yeah he was abusive
toward my mother I never directly to my
brother annoyed but I mean as a result
of witnessing things yeah you saw yeah I
was I was horrific they're the things
that there's some things that we've seen
that you know nobody should go so yeah
my parents divorced when I was about 13
so I've been really close with my mom I
tried until I was about an adult and at
18 is when I had my my big like buck you
get out of my life moment with him
here in there yeah
it's always led a very like your arms
distance yeah so so when yeah there's
this saying that everything that we do
as humans is either an act of love or a
conference call for them how would you
view would you do it porn as if that
saying is true
so if everything is one or the other you
know there's elements of both I think
elements of both in all aspects of life
yeah you know at least what I do I'm I
hope that I'm giving people I mean some
sort of fulfillment pleasure something
you know it just doesn't have to be that
deep but you know I hope some people
will see what I do and and it helps them
discover things within themselves and
and within their dynamics maybe what
they want so that's what I'm giving
hopefully more intimate connections to I
do I do enjoy getting to know fans over
a period of time seeing them at
conventions and such then seeing them
again online it's really nice because it
feels so real it mean it is so that's a
very giving thing that I can do exactly
so I'm also definitely receiving a
compensation for what we do for like
what I do and everything that comes with
it you know I am paid quite nicely when
I'm working often and the attentions
great I'd be lying if I didn't say like
the attention
but yeah it's it's not that simple it's
it's not just giving or receiving just
yeah do you find it you know because
it's messy the act of sex I think is is
a it's a it's an expression of love yes
there is the way you're doing is it's
more like a physical act it's almost
like the love part is to get extracted
from sure it means that it must somehow
play into your personal life and just
yeah absolutely it's complicated to deal
with it must be said that um I can
relate it to maybe dancing or making
music right so if you have something
choreographed and you perform it for an
audience
you're still proud of it and it's
something that you've worked hard on and
that's that's me in front of a camera
it's something it's it is a performance
but it's real it's something I have
quite literally practiced and put time
into and and research and such more it's
more acting than feeling
I allow myself to feel I allow myself to
get into more erotic head spaces I allow
myself to explore just the surface
levels of maybe my scene partner's
favorite King just the little things I
might turn them on nibbling the ear is
maybe like you know put my feet in their
face whatever weird little thing is so
it's that to me is still and to make
something something a little bit special
for them and most of the time they're
receptive and then and return the favor
but there doesn't have to be this this
deeper profound like emotional
attachment it's just like having a dance
partner and that doesn't mean that I
don't go home and dance my heart out
when no one's looking or you know to
have my romantic partner that I don't
have to worry about what I look like I'm
not really worried about where the
lights are at and so I can maybe relax a
little bit more yeah what's your what's
your proudest achievement
but I'm really proud that I can
accomplish double you know that's a
whooping wild / smuggle but in a more
professional sense I'm really proud of
the work I've accomplished as like a
media 7 performer and just an overall
extreme performer I am 26 mm-hmm before
pouring I was exploring BDSM and kink
just on my own because after things
ended with my high school sweetheart I
was suddenly 20 I was out of fashion I
was single and I was just wanted to
explore so my first ever Dom is someone
who also has a pacemaker and that's what
kind of started the conversation and
he's a few years older than me but he
had it installed at the same age 15 so
we got to talk in and we bonded over
being cyborgs and I felt like I could
really trust him because he knows this
condition better than I do
he's also a total nerd which was really
hot because it's like he wanted to he
could a hack of my heart I was like if
somebody hacks my heart I'm gonna know
who did it not hot so it's a bad joke
yeah we did a bunch of medical play and
dungeons so we do play piercings which
are temporary piercings and just see how
many needles you can take we did all
kinds of crazy [__] but we're still
friends to this day
yeah and I've played with many many
amazing kinky partners and
yeah that was all before portent so yeah
I was like oh being in front of cameras
pending over back course I've forgotten
my ankles we'll just put it together
[Music]
yeah I just trying to use myself for my
advantage and not let anybody else shame
me or even make money off of me I do I
do
and I'm very very lucky to now be with
next level thank you yeah I could go on
all day honestly so thank you for having
me